The Titanic, the unsinkable ship, launched
on April 10, 1912, carrying some 2,200 passengers
and crew en route to the United States.
On the night of April 14, 1912, the ship hit
an iceberg and sunk, resulting in around just
700 people surviving—only a third of the
people on board.
However, there were a few lucky people who
survived because a twist of fate when they
didn’t board the Titanic as planned.
In December 1911, Milton S. Hershey, the founder
of the Hershey Chocolate Company, put down
a $300 deposit (about $7,281 today) for a
state room aboard the Titanic.
The check for the transaction, made out to
White Star Lines, is still in the Hershey
Community Archives.
Hershey had founded the Hershey Chocolate
Company back in 1894, and it resulted—as
you probably guessed—in a roaring success.
By 1907, Hershey had his own factory to mass-produce
chocolates and distribute them nationwide,
resulting in enough money to take a lengthy
trip to Nice, France.
On the return home, he thought he and his
wife might as well spend the days at sea lounging
in luxury, which is why he put down the deposit
on the state room.
It’s not certain exactly what caused Hershey
to abandon the Titanic trip at the last minute,
as the company will only say that he found
it necessary to return to the United States
earlier.
There are two theories: first, a pressing
matter at the factory required his attention,
and second, that his wife Kitty had fallen
ill, resulting in an early departure.
Both stories have some weight; Kitty had notoriously
bad health, and the founder of a company would
certainly be required to cut his vacation
short if “an urgent matter” popped up.
Regardless of what happened, Hershey did not
board the Titanic as planned.
Rather, he and his wife hopped on the German
ship Amerika and arrived in the United States
several days before the Titanic sank.
Ironically, the Amerika passed through the
waters the Titanic would be sailing through
and sent word ahead that there were a few
treacherous-looking glaciers along the way,
and to watch out for them.
Obviously, the warning wasn’t heeded.
The Titanic was unsinkable, after all.
Even if he had been on board, Hershey and
his wife would have had a better chance at
surviving than a majority of passengers.
Based on figures given by the British Board
of Trade, 97% of female first class passengers
were saved during the disaster, along with
33% of male first class passengers.
That’s in comparison to the 46% of female
third class passengers, 8% of male second
class passengers, and 16% of male third class
passengers who were saved.